このダンマパダテキストの今日は四十六番目の偈になるんです
偈は
ペーヌーペマンカーヤミマンギリットワ マリーチダンマンアビサンブダノ チェッワナマーラッサパプッカカーニ アダッサナンマッチュラージャッサガッチェ
あの犬を言います ペーヌーペマンカーヤミマンギリットワ マリーチダンマンアビサンブダノ
ペーヌーペマン ペーナっていうのはこの泡なんですね
ペーヌーペマン 泡のように
ウプマンっていうのは例えですね
泡に例えて カーヤンっていうのは体のこと
ミマン この自分の体ですね
ギリットワ 知ってほしいと
自分の ご自分の体は泡のようなものであると
よく知ってほしいと 知るっていうことは
もう単なるあ そうかっていうぐらいの知ることではなくて
ものすごい集中した心で自分の肉体を見ると
泡のようなものであるということは見えるんだそうです
あるいは二行目でマリーチダンマン
マリーチダンマン マリーチっていうのは蜃気楼だと思いますね
蜃気楼のようにという
かげろう  かげろう？こっちじゃないんですけど
かげろうの かげろうのようなものでいてほしいと
アビサンブダノっていうのはまた知ることなんですね
で これはすごい智慧で知ることなんですね
まあ私たちの普通の知識ではそういうふうには見えないかもしれません
で そういうことによって三行目チェッワナマーラッサパプッカカーニ
あのパプッカっていうの
最後の言葉っていうのは花ということで
このマーラってのは悪魔のことで
あの これは神話から出てくる言葉使ってます
この で 仏教でマーラというのは
これはギリシアの話でもこのキューピッドというお偉い方がいるんですね
あの キューピッドですか
日本語で言えば  キューピッド
そのキューピッドが弓を持ってますね
その矢は離れできているんです
それで人を刺しちゃうんだと
こちらのマーラっていうのはその同じものなんです
ヨーロッパの文明を知ってる方から見れば失礼な言い方かもしれませんだけど
なんでキューピッドに悪魔と使いますかと
失礼じゃないかと 一応まあインドでも似ていた信仰神話があったでしょうと思いますけどね
まあとにかく花の矢を持っているマーラをね
チェッワナ それはもう切るということで
もうその悪魔を マーラをもう倒して
アダッサナンマッチュラージャッサガッチェ
マッチュラージュ この仕様に見られないところに行くものであると
大変な言葉なんですけど
まあまあ 私たちの知識
だいたいダマパダだっていうのは
世の中ではこの まあちょっとちょこっと読んで
ああそうか ブッダがそんなことを言ってるんでしょうかというふうに
すごい軽く まあちょっと読んで捨てるような気分のテキストだと
まあ思ってはいるんですけど
皆様そう思ってるんだからそうかもしれませんだけど
たまたまちょっと理解しにくい難しいことも言っているとは思います
そこら辺に まあ誰にでも
まあそうかっていうふうなことで理解できる言葉ではないんです
まあ結局ブッダの言葉ですから
だからブッダの言葉っていうのは理解できないんだから
大体世の中で起こるということっていうのは
自分の知識で理解してやるぞということになるんです
それはしょうがない流れで
だから自分知ってる宗教観念やら概念やら勉強したそこら辺の中から
そういうことを言ってるんだと
ことになるんです だからとっくにすでにご自分が知っている知識の中で理解しようとするんですね
だからブッダっていうのは大したことをおっしゃってないんだと
誰にでもわかる 子供にでもわかる
くだらない単純なものしか言ってないんだということは
堂々と有名人が言うんです
今思い出したんですけど
瀬戸おじさんとかね 釈迦はもう何の大したことは言ってないんだと
で そういうことになる
それはもう 本人たちは嘘をついているわけじゃないんですよ
すっごい深い研究した結果でそう言ってるんです
かなり苦労して かなり苦労して研究するっていうことは
自分の頭の中にあるもう概念の中で
もう何言ってるのかと理解しようとしているんですね
頭の中にある概念っていうのは
俗世間の考え方で貪瞋痴を正当化する
どうすれば人がいかに堕落するのかというね
そういう知識が持ってないんですね
そういう知識を絡み合って絡み合って
この貪瞋痴で逆らった考え方を作るっていうことは大変な努力なんです
だからブッダは大したことを言ってないやと
ブッダと言わない その場合
釈迦ですね で 釈迦が大したことは言ってないんだっていうことになるんです
誰にでもわかることを言ってるんだよ
でも あまり欲張るなよとかね
それぐらいは私たちも知ってますよと
私たちはもっと知ってますよという態度になるんです
あまり怒るなよとかね
ちょっと我慢しろとかね
まあそんなものだよと
で だからもうよく世の中に回る流れっていうのは
とにかくお釈迦様は新しいものは何も言ってないんだと
世の中で他の宗教が言っていることを自分の言葉で言っているだけであって
どんな宗教も同じことだと
だったら仏教に目をかける必要はないんですけど
なぜならば ブッダの教えを信仰する人々っていうのは
世の中でものすごい数が少ないし
その中でも真面目に理解しようとする人々はその中でも少ないしね
だからこの地球の人口の中でね
もう 1000人にも1000万人にもならない人々のことは放っておけばいいんですけどね
自分たちの宗教から世界制覇するなりに世界救うなりにね
よろしいんですけど かなり目をかけているんです
で 私たちの立場は違って
お釈迦様はこの誰にも解くことをできなかったもの
誰にも発見できなかった
できなかったものを最初に語りましたと
で それは最初で最後で
これからもう語れませんと誰にも
で 真理を初めて発見したんだという
ブッダの教えを信仰する人々の立場は
そういう立場なんですね
で もう一つ もう最近思い出しましたけど
また本を注文したんですけど
まだ届いてないんですが
あの 私は瞑想指導するときは
あの たまたま初心者の形々は瞑想する受けたりもするし
全く受けてない方々いますけど
よく言うことがありまして
この私が言う通りに瞑想するならば
これはもう明らかに心はちょっと今までと違った形で心が動くはずですよと
脳細胞も そうなると あの
結構最初はものすごい厳しくて難しいんだと
やり方は でも言ってる文字通りに
ちょっと一日二日三日ぐらいやってみてくださいと
脳にはまるっきり新しい思考回路
神経回路がいっぱい出来上がりますよと
なぜかというと 新しい神経回路がないと
今持ってる神経回路でこの修行法できないんだと
それだったら  どうってことなくて
結構頭良くなりますと
たくさん回路が出来てしまうとね
脳は使えますからね 頭良くなるし
神経回路ができて機能しちゃうと
かなり人っていうのは幸福感感じるんだと
で 幸福感っていうのはもう単なる脳のからくりで
あの 実際に幸福となんとか世の中に客観的にあるわけじゃないんだと
だから脳が幸福を感じるんだから
それは単なる脳の働きだと
だから脳が働かないと機能しないと人間っていうのはものすごく苦痛を感じるし
落ち込むし で 大変あの
人気ある病気がありましてね
日本でこのうつ病ですか
うつ病があって 結構みんな自慢げに言ってるんですね
私はうつやとかね で こんなに誇り高く自慢げに言って私を貶すというね
まあ病気は病気ですけど
このうつ病なんかは まあ私の非科学的な説明っていうのは脳は機能しない
で ある時はうつはなくても
ある時は出てくるとかね
大体中年になってくると出てくるっていうことは結構ありますし
これがまあ脳の使い方まずかったし
まあ若い時は一応体血液やらね
もうよく流れてもう肉体は健康で機能するんだから
脳細胞もそれなりに機能しているんだから
それは感じないんですね
でも間違って方法で脳を使っていると
もうどんどんもう使えなくなっちゃうんですね
ゴミがいっぱい溜まって
で 死んで死んでいくわけですね
脳細胞は その上もう酒飲みますから
脳細胞生き返ってはこないんです
死ぬしかないんです でもそれも私が言うんだから正しくないっていうことになるし
酒ほど体にいいものはないんだというふうに
日本の医学の先生たちは堂々と言っている
で 証拠はどこにあるのかと私が聞きたいんだけど
テレビを通して聞いてるんだから
あれを聞くことはできません
証拠なく偉い方々言うんだから
それまた真理ですね こういうこういうデータあるよと言っちゃうと
もう真理でなくなっちゃうんです
とにかくそういうことだから
うつだから答えは脳を機能させるしかないんです
脳機能回復 機能復活させるためには
薬飲んじゃうともうダメなんです
例えば 足が弱いんだったら
もう散歩しなくちゃいけないでしょうね
じゃあ一日十キロぐらい散歩するんだぞと言って
タクシーに乗って十キロぐらい行って帰ったっても
散歩にならないんだけど
みんなその道選ぶんですね
一日十キロです はい わかりましたと
で ものすごい丁寧に真面目に
毎日十キロじゃなくて十二キロも行ってタクシーで行って帰ると
で 私に報告すると 私は毎日十二キロだよと
散歩に行くんだと どうにもならないんですけども
確かにその人は毎日１２キロぐらいは１０キロだと言って言っているのに
毎日言ってるんですけど
しかし ほら見ろ 病気治せてないんだと
ということで だから足が弱いんだったら
散歩しなくちゃいけないんだったら
これはもうタクシーで行ったっても散歩になりません
足で歩かなくちゃいけないんです
だから道具使ったらダメなんですけどね
脳を開発したければ 薬飲むんじゃなくて
脳を動かすんですよ その時でも今までくだらないことを妄想して脳を使っていたんですが
それで病気になったんだからそのやり方は良くないっていうのは
もう私みたいな単純理屈ばっかりで生きている人間にとってはそれよくわかるんですね
今まで読んだ本やらね
今までやったことやら
今までやってきた仕事やらね
そればっかりやったって
もうそれで病気になったんだからね
だから全くも違うことをやらなくちゃいけないんです
それは全くも違うことだから
それすごいシンプル単純で
ものすごい基本的なところから始めなくちゃできるわけじゃないんです
それも私にしてみれば論理なんですけど
例えばギリシャ語は皆様ご存知ではないかもしれませんだけど
日本語はもうもう日本人だからね
もうものすごい抜群に知っている日本語ならどんな本でも読める
だからギリシャ語もこれ今日から勉強すると思ったところで
いきなりギリシャ語のものすごいぐちゃぐちゃ難しいテキストを読み出すっていうことはありえないでしょう
そこでまずギリシャ語の文字を勉強しましょうってなると腹が立つんです
あんた何様のつもりですか
私たち馬鹿にするんじゃないよと
アルファベット教えて
何よこれよと 言うと怒るんです
でも全く新しいものだから
アルファベットから勉強しなくちゃいけないっていうことは
まあ私から見ればそれは正しいんですけどね
大学にいたある友達がもうずっと言いっぱなしなんですね
自分がものすごい言語達人やと
まあ私はもうそうかなという気持ちもありましたけど
で まあ外国人でしたけど
日本語だけはやっぱりすごい上手なんです
それはすごい立派に書ける
それだけのことなんですけど
それでも誰か誰かが訳したものとか
それをパクっちゃって盗んでなんとかちょっともう書いたって
そんなのはもう学問の世界ではよく知っているしね
それはなんとか人が作った引用はあんた再びそれは禁止なんですけど
研究では 人が引用したものを自分も自分で発見したごとく引用するっていうことは禁止違反ですけど
仏教研究の場合はみんなそういうことをやっています
だから いくら新しい研究テキストできても
全然新しいアイデアが何もない
百年 百五十年前に言った同じことを繰り返しているんです
同じ引用文章なんです
引用した初めて引用した人は
引用の仕方が間違ったとか
脈絡が間違ったならば
それを直そうと全然しない
ずっとそのままで  そういうことで
それでいくつかの英語のテキストを読まなくちゃいけなくなっちゃって読めないんですね
それで私は全部日本訳してあげたんです
でもいつでも自分が知ってるんだと
ただたまたまですから
ちょっとこれ日本語にしてくれませんかと
すごい私は人を頼んだことは昔はもう何でもいいよということで
何も思わず思わないで
すぐやってあげる とにかくもう本人が助かるんじゃないかと
それで十分だと そこで私に頼んで翻訳してもらおうとできなかった
なんとかあって もうなんか自分でもやがて少々あの高慢がもうなくなったんですね
私に見せるために なんとか辞書を引いて引いて
英語の単語に日本語の単語の単語を入れ替えて
これを訳したんですけど
どうですかね この大学に出しますからとかね
そしたら私はこれこれ日本訳でしょうかと
で 本当はこの人が別なことを言ってますよと言って
全部直してあげるところではなくて
そのままあれを捨てちゃって
この単語も全部間違ってるんだと
辞書を引いたら 日本語の辞書ではみんなから英訳できませんと
それから辞書そのものもダメですよと
全部辞書を調べたんだから
同じコピーであって 辞書 二つ買ったんだからといって別な意味取れるわけじゃないんです
すごい昔 誰かが英英辞書を翻訳したんです
その翻訳はずっと続くんであって
だからそういうふうに辞書は書けないんですよ
で 研究してないんだからしょうがないんですけど
そういうことだから 辞書を引いては訳できない
だからで辞書は全く意味がないわけじゃないんです
よく英語を知っている人にとっては
たまたまこの単語は何でしょうかというぐらいだったら
ちょっと調べるぐらい参考になるぐらいなんですけど
それで捨てて新しく訳してあげたんですね
それでその人は ちょっともう一度英語を勉強した方がいいと思いますよと
私もそう思いますよ 教えてくれ
いいよ 私は本を読むぐらいのレベルにはね
大体ヶ月間でやってみせましょうと
本人がその気になってきたんです
それで一応能力は知ってるんだからね
まずもう英語の基本的なシンタックスとスタイルは知らない
例えば This is a pen. というスタイルありますね
そんな立派な英語じゃないんですけど
そのシンタックススタイルさえ知らない
だから主語を取った途端
すぐ動詞を取らなくちゃいけないんですね
それはもう自然に流れてこないと
だからまず基本的なシンタックスやりましょうということで
その人にシンタックスという言葉は言わなかったんです
で これでこういうこういう単語を組み合わせて
この動詞につなげてくださいと
というまず最初の宿題をあげたんですね
それで本人がその挙げた単語で大体文章にしてみれば
六十 八十ぐらい書かなくちゃいけないんです
計算すると でも同じパターンだから書ける
しかし 八十ぐらい文章を書いても
全て文法的にはぴったし正しいんです
それは本人知らない それで頭の中で無意識的に残るんです
そのスタイル で怒られたんです
馬鹿にするんじゃないんだと
そんなの知ってるんだと
しょうがないと それでやめたんです
私の教え方はそういうやり方だと
いきなり難しい本を持ってきて
単語一つ一つ教えてあげて
それからその日本訳を私はしてあげて
知ったぶるになるだけで知ったことになりません
難しい もう特に論文というのはもうものすごい文章
難しいんですよ だから大体この正しいやり方を言うと
そういうことになるなとね
やっぱり怒るんですよ
だから論理的に何か言っちゃうと必ず怒られるという結果っていうのは決まっていて
もう私はもう慣れました
それから だったら怒る人は怒ってもよろしいしっていうことまで
もうしょうがないと そういうプロセスだから
やっぱり脳を新しく神経回路を作ろうと思っちゃうと
すごい単純な基本的な方法で
今まで一度でもやったことがない方法でやらなくちゃいけない
これに結構攻撃するんですね
私はもうずっと茶禅組んだことがあるんだとかね
私はヨガやったことがあるんだぞっていうことにもうすごい
あの すごい もう何て言いますか
この 金剛という道具あるんですね
帝釈天か誰か持っているあの道具では世の中で何でも潰れるんだとという伝説はあります
金剛みたいな刀持っているような感じで私に攻撃しようとしていますけど
もう吹いただけでも落ちて折れてしまうような道具なんですね
だからこの やっぱりこの単純理屈には脳が慣れてないというか
複雑な理屈も慣れてないしね
まあしょうがない 難しいんですけどね
そういうことで この すごいシンプル単純な方法で脳を訓練させると
ものすごい新しい神経回路が出てくる
新しい神経回路が出てくるで
今まで動いてない神経回路にもつなげるんだから
当然 今まである能力もさらに磨いたことにもなるし
たまたまどこかで脳細胞死んじゃったっても平気でしょ
ずっと回路ができてるんだから
ネットワークみたいだから
神経回路も 一つ潰れたんだからって
それからもう電気つなげないっていうことはなくて
別なところからつなげてるんだからね
脳が動くと幸福感感じるんですよ
すごい単純ですけど 別に我々舌で幸福感じるわけないでしょうに
鼻で幸福感じるわけじゃないでしょうに
左足の左手の薬指で幸福を感じるわけないでしょうに
例えば金があるんだから私は幸せだと
金で幸せ感じるわけじゃないんですよ
金があるんだからなんて幸せだと思う人もいるし
金がいっぱいあるのに私はなんて人生不幸だなと思う人もいますからね
ですから この自分が置かれてる状況は幸福でとるか不幸でとるかっていうことは
脳の仕事なんです だから食べるご飯なくてもすごい幸せにいる人もいるし
いくら食べるものが溢れてあっても不幸だと思う人もいるし
だから脳の中でね そういう風なこの運動をしておけば
どうせ人格も変わります
ものの見方が変わるし
元気にもなるし くよくよする必要はなくなっちゃうし
くよくよするできなくなるんです
脳が動いてるんだから
いつでも楽しんでいるんだから
それで人格が変わったということになります
私はそういう説明というのは大体はするんですけど
一人も聞いてくれなかったんです
この馬鹿言うこと聞くのかと
学者でも何でもないではないかという態度を感じるんだからね
偉い態度取っているなと
私もそれに攻撃できません
私は別に脳の専門家でも科学研究している人でも
科学者でも科学知ることもないんです
私は 私は知っている仏教で喋っているだけですからね
そこでこの間 このワンリーさんが何か何とか本を持ってきて
どんな本かと言ったら
これシナプス シナプスできたら人格変わりますよってすごい本があるんだと言って
で そこでその本が真理で事実で
なんかこちらで言っていることにも何か助けにならないのではないかというすごい態度で考えているんですね
だから誰かがそういう本を書いただけで
私たちはサーッと後ろに下がらなくちゃいけないんです
えらいことを人が来たんだと
ずっと昔から同じこと言ってる我々には全然権力はないんですね
それも自分の頭の中で
ブッダの教えにどんな立場が上げているかということなんですね
いつでも裏口 だからどこか馬鹿が
なんかいい加減もうもう
産卵的な研究してくれないまでは
ブッダの話に立場がないという
それに繋げちゃうとまた研究進みますからね
やっぱりブッダはダメです
平気で言うでしょうに
だから今日朝かな？昨日かな
けど まあこれから私にシナプスについて喋ることはできなくなったと
もう日本語しちゃったんだから
あの本は私も読んだことはないんですけど
一応英訳の本を注文してしたんです
それから喋ることになると
もう私の話ではなくて
何々さんがこう言ってるんだよと言わなくちゃいけないんだから
そのように大量に無数に私の考え方
いろいろ言ったことっていうのは
もう捨てなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんです
それからまたあと十年で人間発見する
何か他の別な真理をこれから喋り続けなくちゃいけないんです
まだネタ切れてないんですけどね
私は知ってることのほんの一部しか言ってないんです
ここまで喋っても それも理解してないんだからね
あまり舐めることはできないと思いますけど
ブッダの智慧っていうのは
それで私が言いたいのは
悟りっていうのはこの腐りかけてる脳が開発することじゃないんです
いつでもそれも言ってますよ
それはまだその方々言ってないんだから
まあ誰かさんが研究するまでは私の考え方なんです
脳の運動も肉体の運動と何の変わりもないんです
まあしかし 肉体は健康だったらそれなりにも人間の人格が明るくでしょ
脳が健康だったらもっとものすごい
なおさら人の人格は明るいんですよ
しかし 心の健康が衰えていく
どうなるんですかね 同時にあの明るさは衰れるでしょうね
脳の機能も当然衰えますからね
どうするとその人格も衰えるでしょう
ブッダがそんなものを目指して喋ったわけじゃないんです
最終的な答えだと もう衰えることはないんだよと
だからブッダの悟りの境地は
それなりに脳の開発したから始まるもんなんです
全く脳を使ってない方々の場合は
ちょっと仕事は多いんですよ
まずもう基本的な訓練して
基本的な知識人にならなくちゃいけない
このすごい苦労してというのは
ものすごい単純に理屈で
理性で物事を見られる人間に立ち立ち上がってもらうことにすごい苦労するんですよ
仏教はそれからなんですけど
それにも至ってないのに
もうまたもう私に指導するんだからね
こうではない こうではないかと
だから私はもう無視するの当たり前で
それでまた不機嫌になっちゃうんです
どうにもならない これっていうのは
えらいことを言ったっても
私にはもうゴミ屋というぐらいでもないんだからね
言ってることは もっとものすごい違うんだからね
ですから この一応理性っていうのはいくらかレベルになってからはブッダの教えっていうのはわかるようになる
それからこれは体験してやらなくちゃいけないっていうことに気付くようになるんですよ
で 同じ方法で同じプロセスで全部進めるようにお釈迦様は教えていますから
これはブッダのすごいところなんですね
次から次へと修行法を変える必要はないんです
最初にスタートした方法で最後まで行くんです
それがお釈迦様のすごい発見であってね
そんなのは誰も発見してないでしょうに
だから無知のせいでブッダを侮辱して
なんかあの先生 あの科学者が
あの人が言ってること
なんか仏教にもちょっと似てるんじゃないかとか
すごいことやと言うとね
もうそれはブッダを侮辱することになるんですからね
好き勝手に侮辱するんですけど
私はそういう人々は捨てますよ
間違い見えても教えてあげない
個人的に私に聞くなれば何でも侮辱されてもよせますけど
ブッダを侮辱されちゃうと
もう絶対もうそれは見捨ててあげない
そういう風な  する 一応
で そこでなんでそんな話したんですかというと
これずっとこの 今更このワンギさん
最近発見した本であった出来事は
もうこれから日本の方々も読むでしょうね
だから同じ羽目になりますから
そういうことっていうのは
そういう経験っていうのはずっとありました
ジョン・カバットという人が自分の商売にヴィパッサナーの手法のほんの一部を使ったんですね
アメリカ人に あの人医者でしょうかね
いわゆるこの人間に この体にこの痛みがあるんですよ
どんな薬も効かない 死ぬまでそれに苦しまなくちゃいけないという病気いっぱいありますよ
よくアメリカにあるみたいですね
薬は効かないわ 心理方法効かないわ
で この人はこのヴィパッサナーのアプローチをどこかどうか旅するときはもう耳に入ったでしょうね
タイなんかに行くときには
タイによく行きますからね
それでブッダの名前を消して
宗教の名前を消して 自分が発見したごとく
治療としてやっている
ライセンス持ってる人だから
当然患者さんも行く その本は日本訳したところで
ある人が「あなたもそのジョン・カバット先生の本なんか勉強したらどうでしょうか」と
私の１回講演頼まれて
ヴィパッサナーのやり方
ちょっともう１時間ぐらいで教えてくれと
だから我々の文化もブッダの教え
いかに馬鹿にして貶しているのかというとね
彼らの偉大なる人はジョン・カバットということで
それすごいことあるんだから
それはもうちょっとどういうことかと分かりたいぐらいのことで
なんでああいう人々の我々は奴隷にならなくちゃいかんですかね
宗教なんかもうそんな話持ってくるなよと
我々は好きじゃないんだと
ブッダの名前さえも好きじゃないんだけど
その方法でもうすごいことをやりたいという態度だからね
そうとううまくいくわけないしね
私も親切にしゃべるわけじゃないし
どうせ貶すんですよ こちらも
見事に見せてあげるんです
いかにアホかと こちら攻撃には攻撃態度をする
これっていうのはもうどうにもならない
あってはならない流れなんですね
その流れ 私もすごく好きじゃないんですよ
戦うということは 仲良くすれば何でもうまくいくのに
させてくれないんですね
握手すればいいところでいきなりぶん殴っちゃうと
こちらぶん殴らなくちゃいけないんだから
何もしていないのにこの野郎と言っちゃうと
どうせこちらも腹が立つでしょうね
二度と言わせないよと人に
怒らなくても 喧嘩すればごく一般な喧嘩ね
私はそうじゃなくて もっと厳しい態度を取るんです
人に向かって二度とこの野郎とあんたに言わせないよという
それで厳しい攻撃はするんですね
いつでもそういうことになります
それはまあ何でしょうかと分かりませんだけど
一応物事には方法あります
ダンマパダの場合でも
そういうもういろんな翻訳やら解説とかいっぱいありますけど
だからといって それこそ絶対的な意味というわけでもないんです
我々人間に理解できないレベルもあります
この四十六番はそういう偈一つなんです
このペーノーパマン 泡の如く体を見てほしいと
かげろうのように自分の体を観察してくださいと
言ったらすぐ我々は考えるのは何でしょうかね
今日は一般的な解説するのはやめて
このお釈迦様は考えた解説だけしたいと思っているんです
概念で 知識で 勉強した能力で
自分の体見ても こういう風には見えないんです
たとえ医学のプロが体見たっても
組織やらその組織の機能やら
その機能を司っている
何でしたっけ このあらゆる化学物質あるんだとかね
そういうものしか見えないんです
それもほとんど推測で見ているんですよ
例えばこういう化学物質
血液に入れたら心臓の鼓動が速くなるんだと
血管が広げるんだとかね
そこはもうあらゆる研究して
ああ これやっていう風にもう何とか発見するだけであって
それもまあ推測談ですよ
もう論理的に明らかにこういう機能で
こういう働きでこうなるんだっていうことはないんです
で 頭の病気の場合でも
まあいろんな調べて調べて調べて
普通の正常な人間とどれくらい差があるのかと調べて調べて
おそらくこういう人にはこれこれがない
これこれがない だからこれこれ病気の原因ではないかと
で 推測する でも患者っていうのはモデル的な患者じゃないんだから
だから一つ決めた病気の原因決めても
まだまだ新しい新しい患者さんが調べると
また別な原因があって
また発見したりする だからいろんな薬を考えて考えて
もう体の病気治そうとかね
そういうわけだから 知識でいくら見ても
この肉体はこのままでしか見られないんです
知識のこのすごいこれは障害なんですね
知識と概念というのは
この知識と概念というのは一切捨てて
ただ認識するだけにして
ブッダはそこが真理の世界だというんです
人の考え方で自分も同じこと考えたっても
それは新しいものを知ったことにはなりません
この花は綺麗だという考え方
そういう考え方なんですね
花は綺麗ということは
もう花を経験する前からも我々の頭にこのもうインプットしているんです
それで自分が花を見て
もう確かに花は綺麗で
それは私は知りましたと平気で言うんです
本当はそれは事実じゃないんです
自分の脳に入れた インプットした固定概念をそのまま繰り返して繰り返してリピートしただけ
同じ概念をもう万回ぐらいリピートすると
かなりの概念いっぱい溜まってるんだから
随分同じ概念を反射しているんです
頭の中で それですごい量ですから
すごい知識だと思うんです
だから知識で見るということは
何の意味もないんですけど
知識を避けて物事を見るということは
もう大変な難しい作業になっているんです
で ブッダが言うのは もうそんな外から余計に入れたものを通して見るということは苦しいんじゃないかと
どう見たっても それは捨てて
そのまま自然に見る方が一番自然で楽じゃないかと
本当はブッダの見方は一番楽なんです
数え切れないほど無数の道具を通して何かをやるよりは
もう直接やった方が楽やと
我々のやり方は 例えば自分の目の前で石一個あります
それを取りなさいと言ったら
もう指で取っちゃえば楽でしょうに
指で取らないで じゃあそれはもう何て言いますか
箸で取りましょうと で
箸が入ってくるんですね
そこで自分が石を取ったと
石取ってないんですけど
箸を取ってるんですけど
自分が箸を取った経験があるんですけど
石を取った経験ないんです
それで箸が概念 で その人が石取っても他のものを取っても
何を取っても  100個ぐらいの品物を取っても
その人の経験は橋を取っている経験なんです
いくら自分は私は石 1個じゃなくて 100個取ったんだよと
でも 1個指で取った人には勝てないでしょう
まだどちらの方が楽ですかね
だからこの概念としてたくさん知っているんだと自慢しても
ブッダは何も知らないんだと
それで 1個取った経験もないのが
でっかいトラックに石を運んでも
私はこれぐらい取りましたよと
石 1個も持たないで くっと自分で手で取ってみて
それを捨ててきた人の方が勝ちなんです
知識に対する仏教に対するそういうことで
それでこの橋が概念で
次の人間は概念 1個で足れません
もっとかっこつけなくちゃいけない
もう橋もありますから
もう橋もない人はもう貧しくて貧乏でなんてみっともないやっていう態度でしょうね
だから道具たくさんなった方がもっとかっこいいんですよ
それで橋をつかまる別なものをまた開発する
それを動かすまた別なものを開発する
それに機械まで開発する
橋にもバネでも作って
バネが縮むために別な機械作って
それを管理するためにまた別な機械作って
最後に自分がこのスイッチを押すと
その機械がずっと動いてきて
橋を取って丁寧に石を取って見せると
本人がスイッチを押せばいいのです
そこでもう 100個ぐらいの機械を通して石を取って取ったことになるのかと
楽ですから そのやり方は
だから知識が増えても増えても無知だという態度を取るのです
同じダンマパダにあの
無知な人と智慧のある人の差がいうところで
あの 無知な人はこのスープなんです
スープっていうのはもう料理ですけど
料理の料理を作っている鍋にある匙みたいだと
料理するともう匙を鍋の中に入れてかき混ぜたりするんですよ
だから匙がもう料理でいっぱいなんですよ
でも味がわからないんだと
智慧のある人は 1滴舌についたら味がわかるように
物事は真理わかるんだと
だからいくら法を聞いても
無知な人は匙のようなものであると
智慧のある人は 1個の法も聞いてでも真理わかるんだよという
同じダンマパダにあります
それは後読みますけどね
だからこの物事を知る場合は
この仏教では直接するという方法ね
概念を抜けて知ると ヴィパッサナー瞑想というのは
この概念は割り込まないようにする手段なんです
だからまず概念が割り込まないことを訓練しなくちゃいけない
訓練していると ちょこちょこちょこちょこと直接見えちゃうんですよ
それで十分なんです だから必死になって概念が割り込まないように工夫するしか
個人には他の方法はないんです
見てやるぞという努力はいらん
ずっと認識しているんだから
だから見てやるぞという努力はいりません
概念が割り込まないようにしてすれば
もうたちまち真理が発見できます
真理の発見できます そういうことで
心っていうのは瞬間瞬間変化していくんです
心っていうのは瞬間しか存在しない
ある一つ認識して それでその心は消えちゃうんです
次に別な心が別なものを認識する
そうやって心は流れていくんです
そこはわかった人にとっては
概念抜けて体を体の感覚を認識すると
体っていうのは泡の如く
その瞬間その瞬間現れて消えていくものだ
明確に見えてくるんです
感じてくるんです 泡がブクブクブクブクと出てきて出てきて消えていくと
で これは概念が減っていくと
もう見えている状態なんです
そこでこれって何ですか？びっくりしました
とか まだ概念入り込んじゃうとまた見えなくなっちゃうし
真理わかることはまたちょっと結構延期してしまうんですね
だから方法に厳密に忠実になって
何であろうとも自分が観察だけするんだと
言うと 泡のように感じたんだそうとか
概念作る以前もう進んでいるんです
だから泡のように見えること
影のように見えることっていうのは
この強烈に心を集中して概念を抜けた人にのみ見えるものではありません
それで問題は それって本当なのかという
変な心の状態で見ているんだからおかしいんじゃないかという
普通の人間には反論できます
あんた瞑想なんかやりやがっちゃって
これは変な環境で見たことだからとか
これ事実じゃありませんと言えますけど
ちょっと調べてみるとそれが事実ということはわかるんです
もう単純ですよ で 時々瞑想すると
自分の体が石のようにものすごい硬くなっているのではないかと
これが異常でおかしいやとその人は思うかもしれません
また ある時は体がすごく軽くてふわふわしている状態であると感じたりする
これもちょっとおかしいやと
その時思わない人間ならバカだからね
軽く楽に感じると自分が進んでいると思う
苦しく感じると進んでないと思う
瞑想は そういう固定概念があるんだから
もう 300年ぐらいやってもね
もう逃げませんだからね
同じところにいるんです
ずっと俺の見方で見る見るということは捨てませんから
そこはもういくら私が悪口言ったってもね
もうどうしようもないんですね
とにかく怒鳴らないといけないんですよ
もうだから指導の場合は何やってもあなたのわがままではないかという一言は言わなくちゃいけないことにいつでもなるんです
だから指導する時の戦いっていうのは
この人のこの固定概念
俺の見方で見るぞという
そこはもう捨ててもらうことなんですね
それはずっとその戦いは続けます
一つの概念を捨てると別な概念で見るんだから
それっていうのは まあ心理学的にそういう弱みがあるんだから
そこら辺はちょっと気長く
見ながら まあ放ってはおきます
しかし 負けを認めて全部放棄しない限りは
ブッダの真理の世界には入ることはできない
負けを認めない限りは
俗世間の概念の世界にいるんです
はい 私は負けたという
それ負けじゃないんです
それはインチキ 偽善 堂々と負ける人っていうのは堂々と戦った人なんです
いろいろインチキやって戦って
それは堂々と戦ったことじゃないんだからね
堂々と戦った人が負けたら
もう堂々と見て負けたと
もう疑いの余地もないんだと
だからそれにもインチキできません
微妙にも偽善はいかない
そういう厳しい世界です
それであの瞑想の経験の世界に入れば
例えばもう石のごとく硬く感じると
ああ ダメだ 私の方法間違ってるんではないかとも聞いたりもする
それで また続くならば
まあもう今軽く感じているんだと
で すごいもうニコニコとして報告すると
で 私は全然面白くない顔をしていると
また腹が立って帰ったりするし
どちらが事実で 本人がどちらが事実ないと勘違いしているんですよ
でも我々は体はどうやって感じるんですかね
硬いか軽いかそんなもんでしょうに
ずっと それに概念が入ると
もう体重は六十キロやとかね
自分の身長はこれぐらいだから
これぐらい体重なければいけませんやとか
そんな世界で解説しようとするんです
だからあれが間違いだと
変な 変だと思うだけで
体重は八キロであろうか
四十キロであろうか それと関係なく
その本人がどう感じるのかと
本人が自分の感覚で体を維持管理しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そちらに認識の世界があるんですよ
四十キロの人の体が重すぎて歩けないやということはあるでしょうに
百キロの体なのに何のことなく
もうすごい自由自在に動かしている人いるでしょうに
百キロの体重 百キロなのに自由自在に体を動かす人にとっては体が軽いんですよ
四十キロなのにもうもう疲れた
もう歩けないとかね どこかにもう座らなくちゃいけないんだという人にとっては体が重いんですよ
それが事実なんです 体重計で言ってる数字じゃないんです
体重計が言ってる数字が正しければ
四十キロの人がすごい軽々と走り回っているはずでしょうし
百キロの人はもう百キロも運ばなくちゃいけないんだから
数学で計算するとすごいエネルギー量でしょうに
百キロを一キロを運ぶエネルギーと四十キロを一キロ運ぶエネルギーっていうのは同じじゃないでしょうに
だから物理学のあれっていうのはもう概念であって
生命には関係ないんです
物理学だったらゾウさんなんか歩けないでしょう
だってトン単位だから体重は
人間より軽々と歩きますけど
随分軽々 私はこのゾウなんかを調べてみたところでよくわかることは
体が大きくなればなるほど
動物は人間よりすごい利口だと
で それもまだ世の中で言ってないんだから言います
誰かさんが言ったら私には権利なくなりますからね
で 体が軽い動物っていうのは
一匹でも焦っているんです
落ち着かないんです  [背景音楽]体がすごい軽いんだからもう動かせますよ
でもすぐ疲れます 体が重くなって重くなってくる動物っていうのは焦りがないんです
結構落ち着いているんです
落ち着いているんだから
心のエネルギーは結構あります
だからもう無駄全くないように体を動かすんです
一番体大きいのはゾウですから
ゾウっていうのは他の動物と比べるとものすごい落ち着いているんです
だから混乱していないんだから興奮してないんだから
あの体を軽々と持っていくんです
ゾウでも興奮しちゃうとできないんです
あのエネルギーは出てこないんです
だから体格が大きい動物っていうのは
もう結構落ち着いていて
科学的な説明っていうのは
あれはできるだけエネルギーを保存しているんだということというよりも
もうそんなエネルギーを保存しておくこととは怠けるんだからね
怠けて生きていられませんだから
自然の中で怠けてないんです
ゾウなんか寝ようともしないんだから
怠けるどころか 寝ないでいられる？いるんだから
猫はどうですかね 興奮ばっかしで
ちょっとしたことに １
日中寝ている その代わりに
ゾウは寝てないんですけど
結構 そこでもう誰にも攻撃しないし
たまに子供を守るためにとか
誰か違ってくるともう攻撃しなくちゃいけない
攻撃しないんで それでも
脅すんです で 読む心読めるんだったらよくわかる
これただ脅してるだけだとすぐわかるんで人間にわからないんです
だから大丈夫ですけど
動物にそこまでわからないんです
体が大きいんだから ちょっと音を立てて鼻を出して
あの二 三歩ぐらい前に行って
行ったらもう他の動物たちも人間でもものすごく驚いて逃げちゃうんです
元に戻るんです 見ていると
もうもう全然あれってごまかしですぐ感じるんですね
心の波動で そういう攻撃する気持ちは全然ないんだと
落ち着いているんだからそれができるんですよ
寝ないでいることもできるんです
立って寝る時も立って寝たり
子供は寝れますけどね
ゾウの ペタンと倒れて寝るんですけど
大人は周りそれで周りを輪っかにして子供真ん中に入れて立ってるんです
起きるまで 早く起きろともしない
別に他の仕事もあるわけじゃないんだから
で 立って寝ることはでき
立って寝る時でも 誰か誰かが来ると危ないなと分かったら
体の一部を動かしておくんです
寝ても綺麗にその部分はずっと動いてます
例えばもう体こう動かしてやるぞと思ったら
寝ているんですね 体は同じリズムでずっと動いているんです
鼻を動かしてやるぞと決めちゃうと
鼻だけもう動いている
だから見る人はやっぱり寝てないんだからやばいと近寄ったらいけないと思っちゃう
寝てるんですけど それって人間にできるものじゃないんです
だからかなり心の管理はしているんです
だから何が言いたいかというと
そういうことが正しい働きであって
物理学的に計算したっても
それは知識であって ずっと３時間寝て ３
時間も鼻は振ってるんだったら
これでどれぐらい脳機能しなくちゃいけないかということになるんですよ
だったら寝てないことになっちゃうんですよ
そこら辺説明できんだから
なんとかでごまかしちゃいます
科学世界では そういうことで
ゾウさんが自分の体重をどう感じるかっていうことが事実であって
重く感じるんだったら
ゾウにとっては体動かさないんですよ
ゾウが倒れたらもう死ぬんですからね
もう力尽きてます だから飼ってるゾウでも病気になってくるともう倒れちゃいますよ
倒れるともう何するのかというと
タイでどうするかわからないんで
自分の国だったらもうこれにやら色々持ってきてもうゾウを正すんですよ
横にさせないんです 立っていられないんだったら
もういろいろ工夫して立っていられるように縛っておくんです
それから治療するんです
倒れてるともう薬を飲まない
諦めちゃうんです まあちょっとした病気あれだったらもう強引にもう寝ろよと
もう寝かせますけどね
その時は人間言うんだから寝るんですから
もう終わったと言った途端
もうたちまち立ちますから
老衰でなってくると やっぱり立てておくてもダメだなと思っちゃうと
もうやっぱりもう寿命でもダメだと思ったら
まあ横になってあげしてあげるんです
人間が諦めない限りは
もう寝かしてあげない
一生懸命治療する まあだから心が弱くなった時点でもう運べないぐらい体が重い
心がもう強い元気が生きていなくちゃいけないんだというエネルギーがある時は体が軽いということなんです
だから我々に必要なのは物理的に思い浮かぶことではない
それは同じ体重だからね
物理的には しかし 物質は心の認識によって動かしているんだから
心がどのように認識するのかということが一番大事なことであって
だから人が痩せてるか太っているかということを今はこの形で決めるでしょうね
それが正しくない それは科学的じゃないんです
心が決めるとそれはすごい正しいんです
そういうことで 瞑想する人々の場合は
時々体の重さを認識する
時々重さを認識しないで別なことで忙しくなる
体の重さを認識しない場合は
もう体どうなっているのかとちょっと見たところで軽いんです
重さが認識していないんだから
それでその瞬間瞬間で我々は軽さを感じるし
硬さを感じるし 熱さを感じるし
動きを感じるし そういうものをまとめて概念の世界でいろんなことを概念で
自分というのは結構かっこいい人やとかね
結構体力あるんだとか
そういう世界を作るんですね
体力あるということは
私の血圧はすごい健康的やとかね
私は脂肪溜まってないんだとかね
じゃあ見てみようとか
脂肪チェックして ほら
もうやっぱり脂肪がないんだぞとかね
そういう世界を作るんです
そういう世界は幻覚で妄想の世界で
実は真理の世界は別なんです
そういうことを言いたいんですね
お釈迦様は だから普段あなた方にはこういう風に見えませんよと
しかし 知識をじっと集中して
この瞬間瞬間変化深化している体を見ると
泡の如く 陽炎の如く見えるんだよと
泡の如く 陽炎の如く見える
これが これが本当に心体の状態だと分かったその時
納得行ったならば 瞑想の一段落は一応進んだようです
あれはちょっと異常現象で不可思議だと思っちゃうと
また元の状態です 進んでないんです
経験しても 残念なことに
本来は心はそんなもの
心と体の関係というのはそんなもの
体っていうのはそんなもんやと
と分かったと時点で 世間から得た体に対するあらゆる考え方はもう消えているはずなんです
あの固定概念 全部もうとっくに落ちているはずなんです
シノプシスはなんでありがたいやという話はもうとっくに消えているはずなんです
[背景音楽]